first of all good God uh this is already
my favorite interview I I mean I've
talked to everybody but you are just a
delight and I want to tell you something
which is I've always been a fan of yours
and always found you to be uh just a
inspiring person a lot of ways and then
two years ago You released a video after
January 6th and it's called a servant's
heart you put it out alone it's just you
at your desk talking it was your
response to January 6th and I thought it
was one of the greatest Public Services
I've seen anybody do for their country
because you were elected governor as a
republican but you worked very hard to
be bipartisan and then you came out at
this crucial time and you're adored by
people on the left and the right you've
got fans all over the world who don't
even know what your political
affiliation is and you just talked about
how wrong this was and I thought I said
to all my producers I have got to get
into a room with Arnold Schwarzenegger
at some point and tell him how thankful
I am I really am very thankful for that
and also your post about war and Ukraine
and Russia's Invasion I thought this man
is speaking from the heart he doesn't
care about the consequences he's telling
us the truth and I was uh just blown
away so thanks really seriously all the
we'll get back to you mocking my body
and there's a lot to mock but I I did
want to tell you that I uh I was
heartily impressed and I think you've
done a lot of good so much good well
thank you I appreciate you saying that
and you know it was really actually very
kind of satisfying doing it you know
when you see something that is so wrong
yeah then you want to speak up and you
want to let your voice be he and you
know we are very fortunate that we are
celebrities and we have a lot a huge
following and so when we say something
people pay attention and so that's the
idea is to use that power of influence
and to make people pay attention to
something that is that important such a
very important issue which is to protect
our democracy and to defend our
democracy and to do everything that we
can to do that yeah because it's a very
scary time right now absolutely and I
don't know this airs pretty soon but I
know Mitt Romney just announced that
he's not going to run for Senate again
he's a republican he's another person
who I found a lot to admire about
because he speaks his mind about Trump
and about what's going on in politics
and he just said he he said said in one
quote that I think is coming out he
doesn't he doesn't believe that a lot of
his uh people that he works with in the
Senate really believe in the
Constitution and uh that was terrifying
to me yeah yeah absolutely but you know
I I think that
uh we have gone through difficult
moments in the past yes we should not
forget that I remember that when they
came uh you know to America in
1968 it was the year where they shot
Martin Luther King and where they shot
you know Barby Kennedy
and the convention and the Vietnam War
the hippies were running around everyone
was stoned Beyond them mind including
myself and uh and I love hippie Arnold
I'm just imagining hi Arnold it's all
groovy no the funny thing is I was
totally the opposite but I didn't even
know what it was bodybuilders would take
me
up to San Francisco uh the what is it
called exactly and and and and I would
be sleeping out there overnight and I
would be getting stoned and all this
stuff so it was like it was just a
really weird time I thought it was
American it was quite normal I didn't
even know I was in that in that weird
Zone in America where America was going
through some really incredible
challenges and you know then after that
it was followed up with the you know
Nixon got elected uh which was terrific
but then he screwed up with the
Watergate and there was all that going
on and you know and then finally you
know we we found a leader in Ronald
Reagan and he kind of brought America
back and so you know so that's what we
hoping for now you know I think that uh
Biden is not going to be the guy I don't
think Trump is going to be the guy um
but there's someone out there some it's
getting late though it's getting late
though if you don't want things change
very quickly in politics but there's
there's someone out there in America
because America has a of talent MH so
there's someone out there that has the
energy and the vision and the the
strength uh to bring people together and
to create a new kind of leadership you
know with a new energy and stuff like
that so right now I don't see it but
what if that person is closer to you
right now than you think oh Sona what no
not Sona not looking at him right here
yeah I bring the country together yeah
good the real Conan now you're talking
right with the sword
[Music]
Conan Conan o'ban Conan the
Barian o running mates exactly exactly
yeah I'll run with you you run we'll
clear that whole immigration thing up I
think when you first became Governor
people said well they're so excited they
thought could Arnold Schwarzenegger be
president it's like well no you need to
be born in the United States yeah and
that's when we thought time machine huh
we go back in time you're born in Maine
Coastal Maine we change yes the
Constitution you go back I always talk
about that's a that's a that's a time
travel movie and you've done them where
you go back in time to change the
Constitution so you can be president
instead of the Terminator it's just the
editor yeah yeah I mean when I talk
about the immigration reform that's what
I'm talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah
Arnold schwarzer goes back in time
Jefferson scribbling away wouldn't
really be Jefferson if it's the
Constitution but let's just play with
that anyway sir what are you doing here
get out of the
way give me that
quill I told you I'll be
[Laughter]
back